New York City Downtown Manhattan wir
sind in Chinatown einer der lebendigsten
Orte der Stadt viele hier Einwanderer
aus Hongkong Taiwan oder China viele
geflohen vor der Repression der
Kommunisten
wir haben uns mit einem Mann verabredet
der chinesische Agenten ausgebildet hat
bevor er in die USA geflohen ist heute
arbeitet er als Anwalt in New York
vertritt unter anderem chinesische
Dissidenten
Mike Kauf führt uns an einen Ort der
deutlich macht wie unverfroren Chinas
Kommunisten mittlerweile vorgehen um
ihre Kritiker überall auf der Welt
aufzuspüren
sie haben hier sogar eine Polizeistation
aufgebaut das heißt die chinesische
Regierung hat in einem anderen Staat
eine Polizeistation aufgebaut für die
USA ist das völlig inakzeptabel
ohne die Behörden der USA davon zu
informieren wird in diesem Gebäude im
vergangenen Jahr die Polizeistation
eröffnet übernimmt sie hoheitliche
Aufgaben in China selbst wird dieser
Schritt von den Behörden gefeiert
sie wollen allen klar machen die
chinesische Regierung ist überall dass
sie ihre Gesetze überall auf der Welt
durchsetzen können
das ist ihre Zentrale Absicht sie wollen
den Menschen zeigen wie mächtig sie sind
auf einer Pressekonferenz sind Peking
auf die illegale Polizeistation
angesprochen aber wiegelt der
Außenamtssprecher ab alles ganz harmlos
die Mitarbeiter dort würden nur
Führerscheine von Auslands Chinesen
verlängern und andere schlichte
Hoheitsaufgaben übernehmen
es handelt sich nicht um
Polizeidienststellen die Aktivitäten
dort werden von örtlichen Organisationen
der chinesischen Gemeinde durchgeführt
und das freiwillige Personal besteht aus
lokalen enthusiastischen chinesischen
Bürgern und nicht aus chinesischen
strafverfolgungsbam
noch ein Dokument der chinesischen
Regierung dass uns vorliegt spricht eine
ganz andere Sprache
und in diesen Dokument heißt es dass die
Polizei der Stadt futurien jetzt als
erste Stadt eine
überseealarmdienststelle eingerichtet
hat deren Aufgabe ist unter anderem sei
entschlossen gegen illegale und
kriminelle Aktivitäten vorzugehen die
Übersicht Chinesen betreffen
verdeckt der Mitte des FBI wollen wissen
was ich genau in der Polizeistation
abspielt im April schlagen die
US-Behörden zu verhaften luigian one die
Köpfe der Operation als die dabei sind
Beweise zu vernichten
beide werden als ausländische Agenten
angeklagt die in den USA für die
chinesische Regierung Menschen
aufgespielt haben sollen
Holden Triple bei FBI-Agent Direktor für
Gegenspionage im Nationalen
Sicherheitsrat der USA chinesische
geheimdienst-operationen auch die
Kritiker unter Druck zu setzen hätten in
den vergangenen Jahren stark zugenommen
erzählt er uns
sie glauben dass die chinesische
Diaspora wo auch immer sie sich befindet
von ihnen regiert werden sollte es ist
fast eine nationalistische Sichtweise
dass alle Personen chinesische
Abstammung selbst wenn sie drei vier
oder fünf Generationen zurückliegen ihr
Einfluss gewesen sind sie haben echte
Sorgen dass unter den Auslands Chinesen
in der Diaspora eine China kritische
Gruppe entstehen könnte sie wollen in
der Lage sein das zu kontrollieren und
zu überwachen in ihren Augen ist dies
also eigentlich keine Angelegenheit die
die USA betreffen sollte
kalifornia wir sind auf dem Weg nach
jermo am Rande der Mohave Wüste es ist
eine Geschichte wie aus einem
Spionagefilm
mitten im Wüstensand Skulpturen die kein
Zweifel daran lassen und der Künstler
der sie erschaffen hat politisch steht
es ist die Geschichte einer wilden
spionageoperation die zeigt wie weit
eine Großmacht geht um ihre Kritiker
mundtot zu machen selbst hier in der
Wüste zwischen Los Angeles und Las Vegas
wir haben uns mit dem Bildhauer
generalming verabredet jan ist aus China
vor den Kommunisten über Neuseeland in
die USA geflohen er schafft Skulpturen
die sich kritisch mit der chinesischen
Regierung und wie er sagt mit ihren
Lügen auseinandersetzen seine Geschichte
zeigt wie ausgeklügel und perfide Chinas
Geheimdienste dabei vorgehen wenn sie
ihre Kritiker zum Schweigen bringen
wollen
mein kunstagent aus New York rief mich
an und hat gesagt er habe einen Kunden
der mich besuchen wollte das geht ich
habe gesagt klar natürlich kann er
kommen
der Kunde den Chance kunsttangen in die
Wüste bringt ist ein weißer Amerikaner
aus Florida der gibt sich als
Abgesandter eines reichen jüdischen
Kunstsammlers aus mit den besten
Kontakten in die Demokratische Partei
der reiche mir zählen so der Abgesandte
wolle James Kulturen kaufen um ein
Demokratie Museum aufzubauen besonders
interessiert er sei an der Skulptur
China Virus an der Channel und seine
Mitarbeiter gerade bauen
das hier ist der Ort an dem die Skulptur
gebaut wurde und wie sich später
herausstellt immer unter Beobachtung
chinesische Agenten 10.000 Kilometer
entfernt von mir
jan ist bereit zu verkaufen und bekommt
eine Anzahlung von 25.000 Dollar der
reiche jüdische Sammler selbst wolle
aber anonym bleiben so sein Abgesandter
doch er habe eine Bitte
er hat gesagt oh mein Boss ist sehr
interessiert an deiner Arbeit
er hat keine Ahnung wie man Skulpturen
baut würdest du uns erlauben zwei
Kameras zu installieren eine da und eine
da drüben damit man alles sehen kann
nichts Böses und stimmt zu der
Abgesandte installiert die Kameras doch
die Live-Bilder von Channel und seinen
Mitarbeitern landen nicht bei einem
reichen jüdischen Mädchen sondern direkt
auf einem Server in Hongkong wie das FBI
herausfindet verdeckt Ermittler sind dem
chinesischen Agentenring auf der Spur
drei Agenten sind mittlerweile in den
USA angeklagt in der Anklageschrift
heißt es die Angeklagten Zitat
haben vereinbart als Agenten der
chinesischen Regierung zu arbeiten und
sind beteiligt gewesen an einer
transnationalen unterdrückungsoperation
gegen antikommunistische Aktivisten auf
amerikanischem Boden
die chinesischen Agenten aber spionieren
nicht nur chen seine Mitarbeiter und ihr
Atelier aus sie wollen auch an James
Steuerdaten und versuchen ein us-steuer
Beamten zu bestechen
die chinesischen geheimdienstaktionen
würden seit ein paar Jahren immer
aggressiver das stellen die US-Behörden
fest
die haben
wenn du mit Kunst zum Beispiel China
oder die chinesischen Kommunisten
kritisierst dann wollen sie dir eine
Botschaft senden wir kommen jederzeit an
dich ran egal wo du bist auf der Welt
das ist völlig unakzeptabel und zum
anderen hängt das mit der
Machtkonzentration bei Chinas
Präsidenten zusammen wir sehen immer
mehr geheimdiensteinheiten quasi
übereinander stolpern weil sie ihm ihre
Loyalität beweisen
Kopf der Gruppe die generalming
überwacht ist nach FBI Ermittlungen der
reiche Geschäftsmann Frankl mit seiner
harmoniestift und die als kabadina
engagiert er sich bei den Vereinten
Nationen pflegt Kontakte bis in die
allerhöchsten Kreis
tatsächlich aber spürte für die
chinesische Regierung so das FBI
Dissidenten auf mit dem Ziel sie
auszuspionieren und unter Druck zu
setzen damit sie schweigen
hier aber es ist nicht dabei geblieben
Channel und seine Mitstreiter nur zu
überwachen wie es aussieht sind die
Spionen am Ende der Operation noch einen
Schritt weiter gegangen
Herze ist die Kommunisten die
chinesische Regierung hat dieses Kultur
niedergebrannt
sie wollten nicht dass die Menschen die
Wahrheit sehen
beim ersten Mal haben sie versucht sie
abzusägen und umzureißen aber sie haben
es nicht geschafft eine Woche später kam
sie dann so gegen 6 Uhr abends zurück
und haben die Skulptur abgefackelt
Besucher bemerken Rauchentwicklung eines
Kultur und Filme mit ihrem Handy rufen
die Feuerwehr werden das Kunstwerk steht
innerhalb kürzester Zeit in Flammen die
Feuerwehr kann die Skulptur nicht retten
wer die Skulptur abgefackelt hat konnte
bisher noch nicht ermittelt werden fest
aber steht die Operation war ein
Misserfolg auf ganzer Linie denn Jenner
deine neue Skulptur gebaut diesmal aus
Stahl und verwüstlich
wenn die USA und andere nicht dagegen
halten und sie überlegen gerade genau
wie sie dagegen halten könnten dann wird
China versuchen die Situation weiter zu
eskalieren dann werden sie dazu
übergehen nicht nur die chinesische
Diaspora zu überwachen sie werden
versuchen jeden zu überwachen und zu
kontrollieren der sich kritisch mit
China beschäftigt das könnten
Wissenschaftler sein und Journalisten
und wir wissen dass sie schon hinter
einigen Politikern her sind
und solche Operationen finden nicht nur
in den USA statt wir haben uns mit der
kanadischen Parlamentsabgeordneten Jenny
Quan seinen Videocall verabredet sie
selbst hatte gerade ein Treffen mit dem
kanadischen Geheimdienst
sie haben mich darüber informiert dass
ich seit einiger Zeit aufklärungsziel
der chinesischen Regierung bin
tatsächlich seit gut zwei Jahren
und sie meinten dass ich wahrscheinlich
auch weiterhin Ziel sein werde
sie nennen das Evergreen target
[Musik]
Jenny Quan engagiert sich als
Abgeordnete in Kanada für Demokratie und
rechts statt in China und Hongkong sie
ist mit ihren Eltern als Neunjährige aus
Hongkong nach Kanada ausgewandert sie
darf nicht über Details der mittleren
sprechen aber es ist ein offenes
Geheimnis dass Chinas Kommunisten
Kritiker im Ausland damit bedrohen
Angehörigen Hongkong oder China zu
bestrafen oder verschwinden zu lassen
und das habe Konsequenzen
ich habe vor ein paar Wochen an einem
Protestmarsch für Demokratie
teilgenommen viele Leute trugen Masken
obwohl es aus gesundheitlichen Gründen
nicht notwendig war aber sie trugen
Masken um Ihre Identität zu schützen
weil sie befürchteten er kann zu werden
andere Namen gar nicht erst teil weil
sie Angst hatten auf irgendeine Weise
identifiziert zu werden schon jetzt hat
Chinas Vorgehen eine abschreckende
Wirkung auf unsere demokratischen
Prozesse
die kanadische Polizei untersucht
derzeit mehr als 100 Fälle in denen
chinesische Behörden Druck auf
kanadische Staatsbürger ausgeübt haben
sollen darunter auch viele
Parlamentsabgeordnete und in einem
außergewöhnlichen Aufruf auch über
soziale Medien wart der kanadische
Geheimdienste davor das Chinas
Geheimdienste Kanadier innerhalb und
außerhalb Chinas im Visier haben
Kanada und die westlichen Demokratien
müssten der chinesischen Regierung
ernste Frage stellen mein Jenny Korn
versuchen sie etwa unsere Bürger
einzuschüchtern versuchen Sie unsere
Demokratie zu unterdrücken versuchen Sie
Chaos in unserem System zu stiften so
viel Angst zu verbreiten dass es unser
demokratisches System zerreißt ist es
das was sie wirklich erreichen wollen
denn sie versuchen sicherzustellen dass
Ihre Botschaft anders Denkenden nicht
nur überzeugt sondern sie versuchen auch
unser demokratisches System auszuhebeln
also das ist eine sehr ernst zu nehmende
Angelegenheit
zurück in New York die illegale
Polizeistation wurde von den US-Behörden
dicht gemacht die Agenten verhaftet und
angeklagt und das aber sei nur ein
Tropfen auf den heißen Stein in China
betreibe weltweit mehr als 100 solche
Einrichtungen viele in Europa mindestens
zwei in Deutschland sagt uns der
ehemalige chinesische Agent Mike GAU
for German ich denke Deutschland sollte
auch Aufwachen es geht nicht nur um
wirtschaftlichen Vorteil und gute
Geschäfte zwischen Deutschland und China
ihr müsst euch Sorgen machen um eure
nationale Sicherheit
denn die chinesischen Polizei und
geheimdienstoperationen wie hier in den
USA hätten das Ziel die nationale
Souveränität westliche Demokratien
langsam aber stetig aufzuweichen